[موسيقى] إذا لم تكن مستعدًا للعمل الجاد فلن تنجو مني لأن هذه هي شهرة المدرسة في نهاية اليوم ، إنها ليست مدرسة سهلة ، فنحن لسنا هنا في شهر العسل على الرغم من جائحة الفيروس التاجي ماركوس إيتون الذي افتتح الشهرة لأول مرة مدرسة الطهي هذا الصيف ، تشتهر مدينة الواحة الواقعة على بعد حوالي ساعتين جنوب القاهرة بالزراعة ، وسرعان ما أصبحت واحدة من أفضل وجهات الطعام في مصر ، وتأتي توقعات ماركوس من أربعة عقود من الخبرة ، تبدأ الآن 25 دقيقة. في جميع أنحاء العالم وهنا في مصر ، ساعد في بدء العديد من المبادرات التعليمية مثل إنشاء جمعية الطهاة المصريين إذا لم تبدأ في رد ما كسبته جيدًا أثناء وجودك هنا ولهذا السبب أردت أن يجتمع طلاب تعليم فنون الطهي في مدرسة الطبخ في مطعم ماركوس من الاثنين حتى الأربعاء لمدة 10 أسابيع ليس لتعلم وصفات محددة ولكن لإتقان المهارات الأساسية في تقطيع الخضار  طاولات طهي اللحوم وخلط
الخليط
يمكن للزوار حجز دروس خاصة ولكن
هذه المدرسة مخصصة للمبتدئين الذين
يأملون في دخول صناعة الأغذية ،
لقد كان الوقت مبكرًا لمدة 14 دقيقة لأننا
أضفنا بياض البيض
الذي فقدته لمدة 15 دقيقة ، وهدفه النهائي
هو
تمكين الجيل القادم في مصر من الذهاب
في مجال الأعمال التجارية لأنفسهم
وتعزيز مشهد الطهي في البلد الذي
قمت بفحصه هنا ، لقد جعلناه نعم ، لا ، لم تقم
بطي البيضة بعد 14 دقيقة ،
فهذه الصناعة لديها الكثير من
الفرص وبدأت أفكر في
يوم ما يمكنني فتح  أنت تعلم أن
مطعمًا صغيرًا لا يجب أن يكون الجميع
طاهياً ،
فإن وظيفتنا تحمل الكثير من المسؤولية ،
فهي تحمل الكثير من التوتر
ولكن أيضًا الكثير من الفخر ، نحن كطهاة يجب
أن نقدر
هذه الهدية التي نحصل عليها من المزارعين
من خلال النمو من
تستفيد بذور ووتر ماركوس من هذه الهدايا
الوفيرة جدًا في الشهرة ، ولكنها
تضم أيضًا تخصصًا إقليميًا آخر لأ
كل وجبة يتم تقديمها على هذه ال
طباق المصنوعة يدويًا في
رية التونة  تشتهر شركة e
بصناعة الفخار
المخصّصة لأخلاقيات عمل ماركوس في
خلق التكملة المثالية لطهي
[الموسيقى] الخاص به